[Musique]
installé dans l'hémicycle du palais de
la source est très concentré ses élèves
de primaire et collège vivent leurs
finales des concours du cdas
d'orthographe et de calcul rapide
les résultats sont connus dès la fin de
la journée et les gagnants sont
largement récompensés
sur l'épaisseur présent plus
moi pour bien tester
et enfin de connaître
mes capacités match
et tu pensé gagner aujourd'hui non je ne
pensais pas du tout gagné aux pompiers
koné
pour ce 24e et championnat régional
d'orthographe
ils sont cent dix neuf finalistes à
réfléchir sur ladite et d'un texte de
l'écrivain local patrice trop tard au
départ ils étaient trente deux mille
participants
quant à cette 14e édition du concours de
calcul rapide sur les quinze mille
participants
ils sont seulement 12 en finale à se
confronter à des calculs complexes ans
nous avons c'est un peu chez nous les
correcteurs par les progrès faits
prouvent les constaté l'enfant il est
innocent il pourrait en vidéo les deux
bouts alors cette motivation il doit
abriter l
des locaux donc le style eu le conseil
départemental via le cdas tient ainsi à
valoriser le travail de ces jeunes et
continuer à leur apporter du savoir et
de la culture
[Musique]